how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some spider-man
no way home news we have a little quick
video that is kind of giving us more of
a confirmation of who the main villain
is in spider-man no way home
and of course we have a trailer update
it's been over a week since i've done an
actual trailer update video and since
then we have had some things start
happening but don't worry i'll be
breaking it all down
in this video and also if you're not
aware my marvel chair
giveaway has started just click the link
in the description down below to enter
so before we get into the trailer
updates because there is a little bit to
talk about today
let's go over this quick video that's
coming from collider where they did
an interview with willem dafoe who of
course played the green goblin
and the sam raimi toby maguire
spider-man films the first villain that
toby maguire spider-man went up against
now just let me give you a little bit of
context for this because it is a quick
clip
collider frosty asks willem dafoe what
projects he has recently
filmed he names a few and then he says
this
well the other things that i've been
doing lately i prefer to wait until
we're
ready for them to come up so he says
the other things speaking about the
other things that he's filmed
i prefer to wait until they're ready to
come out with them
and this is kind of funny and kind of
interesting at the same time because
there's usually not too many projects
that actors film
that they have to be pretty secretive
about usually the movie is announced
way ahead of time and you know the cast
is usually announced way ahead of time
as well
but of course we do know one very
particular movie that is very secretive
right now
the cast has not been announced really
and that is the way that the studio or i
should say studios particularly wants it
and that of course is spider-man no way
home now we've had reports from several
different trades
including collider talking about how
willem dafoe's green goblin
is going to be the main villain of
spider-man no way home
that came after actual confirmation that
jamie foxx's electro would be returning
in this film
confirmed by jamie foxx himself and
alfred molina's doc op would be in this
film confirmed by alfred molina himself
as well
and it seems like since then some of the
people at sony and marvel may have
talked to the actors and said hey
don't mention what we're doing don't
mention that you're going to be in
spiderman no way home it's a big secret
we're
trying to do the multiverse we're trying
to keep it a secret we're failing
miserably at keeping it a secret but
we're still gonna do the best we can
until that first trailer or the main
trailer comes out
and hopefully when it does hopefully
we'll get a little bit of reveals which
i am about to talk about
but this interview is rather funny
because it definitely gives us more of a
confirmation that he is indeed going to
be the main villain
spider-man no way home is the big secret
right it's the film that he can't say
that he's in
or as he said prefer to wait to talk
about until
they are ready and they is obviously
referring to the studio
sony and marvel and disney and this
seems a little bit too coincidental to
me so i'm gonna go ahead and say he is
definitely talking about spider-man no
way home now speaking of when studios
are ready to
reveal the cast and crew of the movie we
do have a little bit of a trailer update
and this is coming from daniel richmond
daniel rpk on twitter who has a very
very excellent track
record when it comes to trailers coming
out now a couple of days ago on twitter
he tweeted that he's heard some big
trailers are going to be coming next
week
however he did state but still no
spider-man
obviously this is a huge bummer but if
everybody is going to be talking about
trailers next week
everybody would probably be thanking
spiderman no way home so it's good to
have some clarification that no it's not
coming next week
as to what trailers are coming that's
another video let's stick to spiderman
for now because
yesterday we also learned something very
very interesting about the trailer and
about the marketing for no way home
the disney marketing president assad
ayaz talked to the hollywood reporter
yesterday about some specifics about the
marketing campaign for spider-man no way
home
and here we learned that sony is
handling pretty much all of the
marketing for no way home
but kevin feige is heavily involved
here's exactly what he said
sony is absolutely handling the
marketing for spider-man
kevin feige and his team are closely
partnering with the sony team on those
so there is coordination in that sense
we also make sure we are aware of who is
dropping
what when but we are not working
together on the campaigns because
it's their film they are handling it but
there is a level of coordination to make
sure that it's a win-win
for everybody now one of the big
questions that everybody has been asking
and wondering including myself
is are we actually going to see toby
maguire spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man if they
are indeed in the film which i truly
believe
are we gonna see them in the trailer and
now there seems to be
a little bit of speculation about that
and a little bit of debate daniel rpk
stated on twitter if it was just sony
handling it i would have had no doubt
about toby and andrew showing up in the
trailer but since kevin feige is
involved i'm not so sure anymore i guess
we'll see
so keep in mind during captain america
civil war there was a lot of talk about
spider-man showing up
of course at the time a lot of people
were saying that this is
absurd sony owns the rights to
spider-man and marvel studios does not
have those rights
captain america civil war is an mcu film
so
spider-man can show up well of course
there were talks that well they struck a
deal and spider-man
could now be in the mcu and he was going
to appear in captain america civil war
and of course there were still a ton of
people who didn't believe that and
thought no way
so what did marvel do they actually
revealed spider-man in the second
trailer for captain america
civil war obviously big confirmation and
we're kind of
almost in a very similar boat right now
there is a lot of evidence out there
and a ton of talk and reports that toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man are going
to appear in spider-man no way home of
course along with alfred molina's doc
ock
jamie foxx's electro willem dafoe's
green goblin and then of course we have
all these rumors about kirsten dunst
emma stone
a bunch of people this has been called
by a lot of people including
me many times hollywood's worst kept
secret
and it really is so the question is does
sony just come out and show us in the
first trailer or the second trailer
toby spider-man andrew spider-man dock
green goblin do they just come out and
show us
everybody that we pretty much know is
already going to be in the film
or do they wait until the actual movie
releases i think i have to agree with
daniel i think if it was just sony we
would probably see all of the other
spider-man and i do
actually think that during the final
days and possibly a couple of weeks
before we get the actual movie
they will reveal another spider-man
because we know how this works right it
happened for spider-man far from home it
happened for avengers inn game it pretty
much happens for any mcu
project about a few weeks before the
movie actually comes out we get
a ton of tv spots like every other day
we get a new tv spot
and at spider-man people will definitely
go to the theaters to see it or watch it
on disney plus or wherever
but if you want it to be a movie that
completely shatters the box office
records specifically in a time that is
in a pandemic kind of a post-pandemic
you definitely show the other spider-man
because that's what's going to get
people to flood to the theaters and
that's what's going to generate a ton of
hype
a ton of reports on major stations on tv
plus all over youtube and the internet
the reveal is how you get normal people
not people like us who love this stuff
and read about it and talk about it
every day but normal people to go watch
the film
even though i consider them the weird
ones and us the normal ones but anyways
but it looks like the first trailer for
spider-man no way home unfortunately is
not coming next week when reports that
the trailers were sent to theaters first
came out it looked like we were going to
be getting it in june
or july and it looks like that is still
the case but daniel rpk recently has
stated that it could be
early july and daniel does have a
patreon where he does talk about some
inside information that i'll link down
below if anybody's interested but stay
tuned i'll update if i hear anything
else so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos
be sure to let me know your thoughts on
if the other two spider-man are going to
appear
in the trailers down in the comments
don't forget to like the video and for
live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
you